♪ ♪
>> Bret: THE SECRETARY OF THE
INTERIOR SAYS THERE IS NO WAY HE
WILL APPROVE TAKING NAMES OF
PAST PRESIDENTS AND AMERICAN
LEADERS OFF OF GOVERNMENT
FACILITIES, MONUMENTS IN
WASHINGTON, D.C.
CHAD PERGRAM BOOKS AT WHAT’S
BEHIND THIS EFFORT FROM THE
WASHINGTON MONUMENT.
>> THE JEFFERSON MEMORIAL.
AT THE WASHINGTON MONUMENT.
COLUMBUS MOUNTAIN AND CIRCLE.
A WASHINGTON, D.C., ADVISORY
COMMITTEE WANTS TO REMOVE ALL OF
THOSE MONUMENTS.
THE COMMISSION TARGETED SUCH
MONUMENTS AND STATUES BECAUSE
THE HONOREE BACKED SUCCESSION,
OWNED -- EVEN THOUGH MANY OF
THOSE FIGURES WERE INSTRUMENTAL
IN THE FOUNDING OF AMERICA.
REPUBLICANS ARE INCENSED.
>> IF ARE GOING TO TALK ABOUT
REMOVING THINGS, LET’S GET
SERIOUS ABOUT WHAT AMERICANS
THINK OF -- MANY AMERICANS COME
TO WASHINGTON, D.C., TO SEE THE
WASHINGTON MONUMENT.
>> INTERIOR SECRETARY
DAVID BERNHARDT TWEETED THAT
CHANGING THE NAMES AND POSSIBLY
RELOCATING THE STATUES WOULDN’T
HAPPEN ON HIS WATCH.
THE DEATH OF GEORGE FLOYD
TRIGGERED MARAUDERS TO RIP DOWN
AND VANDALIZE SOME CONFEDERATE
STATUES AND OTHER MONUMENTS,
SOME EVEN WHICH WEREN’T
CONTROVERSIAL.
NANCY PELOSI REFUSED TO CONDEMN
A MOB IN THE CITY OF HER BIRTH.
BOTH OF THEM DEDICATED WHEN HER
DAD WAS MAYOR.
>> IF THE COMMUNITY DOESN’T WANT
THE STATUE THERE, THE STATUE
SHOULDN’T BE THERE.
>> MANY REPUBLICANS BELIEVE THIS
HAS CONSEQUENT AS FOR DEMOCRATS.
>> ONCE YOU LET THESE
RADICALS -- THERE WILL BE NO
STOPPING THERE AND WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT REMOVING STATUES, YOU’RE
NOT DOING ANYTHING TO BENEFIT
ANYONE WHO’S LIVING IN POVERTY.
>> THE INITIAL LIST CALLING FOR
THE REMOVAL OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT MEMORIALS IS NOW
STRIPPED FROM THE CITY’S WEBSITE
WEBSITE.
D.C. MAYOR MURIEL BOWSER ASKED
THE WORKING GROUP TO REFINE AND
CLARIFY THE WORK AND FOCUS ON
LOCAL D.C. MONUMENTS, NOT
REMOVING IMPORTANT MONUMENTS AND
MEMORIALS IN THE CITY.
>> THERE’S CONCERN THAT RADICAL
INITIATIVES LIKE THESE PUSHED BY
LIBERALS COULD ALIENATE SWING
VOTERS AND MODERATE DEMOCRATS
AHEAD OF THE ELECTION.
AND BESIDES, HOW DO YOU MOVE THE